un nouveau centre de vaccination contre
le coc vie 19 inauguré ce lundi à la
gare termini de rome 1500 personnes
pourront y être ainsi vacciner chaque
jour et 11 autres centres de ce type
devrait ouvrir prochainement dans des
gares du nord et sud de l'italie une
accélération de la campagne de
vaccination alors que le pays vient de
dépasser la barre des 100000 morts
le 10 mars il y un an l'italie s'est
fermé vivant pour la première fois un
confinement à l'italien sur 20 étaient
infectées selon des données officielles
qui comme on le sait sous-estiment la
propagation du virus
nous n'aurions jamais pensé qu'un an
plus tard nous nous retrouvrions face à
une situation d'urgence similaires et
que le nombre officiel de morts
approcherait le terry le seuil des cent
mille morts et chantôme il a marqué il
faut dire que la situation
épidémiologique dans le pays ne cesse de
se dégrader
le nombre de cas hebdomadaires dépasse
les 140 mille cas 'l'indice de contagion
lui est passé au-dessus du seuil de 1
pour la première fois depuis sept
semaines
conséquence une pression accrue sur les
hôpitaux avec onze régions sur les vins
dépassant le seuil critique des 30 %
d'occupation des lits en soins intensifs
le confinement de toute la péninsule est
donc plus que jamais à l'ordre du jour
c'est d'ailleurs ce que préconise le
comité technique et scientifique pour
enrayer la progression des variantes
dans le pays notamment anglais un
confinement total du pays qui aurait
davantage selon les autorités de
permettre une accélération de la
campagne de vaccination
nous allons devoir poursuivre un double
objectif
d'un côté nous allons devoir faire
baisser plier cette courbe des
contagions un moment où les variants
rendent malheureusement le virus plus
difficile à gérer
plus rapide dans sa capacité à
contaminer les gens et donc nous devons
rappeler tout le monde à la prudence
maximale car les semaines que nous avons
devant nous ne serons pas facile en
attendant un éventuel confinement une
avancée du couvre feu établi en ce
moment à partir de 22h est envisagée
tout comme une limitation des
déplacements durant les week-ends samedi
un nouveau décret à renforcer certaines
mesures dans les régions les plus
touchées avec la fermeture des écoles
pour une période de douze jours
renouvelables au total 6 millions
d'élèves sont concernés depuis lundi